[Music]
three two one action welcome back to out
the perfect where we talk about I panic
for a second like say it say it right we
got new it's the watermelon sparkling
much how come your leads different oh
because it's not one of these guys
Berkeley it sparkles you I used it as
well I love you don't use a you like my
favorite one here though is the
strawberry mmm it's the strawberry so
cream matcha it's very good has boba
what did you give Mike uh ceremonial
matcha I don't know what any of that
means but it's tasty do you feel very
ceremonial I always do big ceremony
doing weddings matrimony
all those words ceremony why do let's
call it ceremonial there's two kinds
they're straight up and in their
ceremonial ceremonial grade is a higher
grade because that's what the Royal is
used to drink well that's why it's
called tea ceremony rightly were you
like kneeling on the floor so when you
guys happy will order the regular one
you guys look at them back no I mean
it's just different
peasants it's not lower quality it's
just tastes different that's all it is
one is more subtle and then one is more
stronger my taste buds are shy because I
can't tell the difference I've even
gotten it where it's like really
ceremonial and straight up and and then
not sweetened as well as I can't tell
the difference for straight up I think
it tastes better with mixed drinks
because it's actually a more bitter
stronger flavor and then when it comes
to ceremony oh it tastes cleaner and
it's too subtle to be mixed with regular
drinks because if you mix it with the
ceremonial that's when you'll know cuz
you're like I could barely taste the
Macho Man true it's like alcohol it's
like the the crappier the alcohol is you
want to mix it
I don't know the higher tier stuff
you're like drinking straight well with
Mike we've been mixing the nice alcohol
with with your margarita through wow it
tastes better I think I mean you have
really like I've had or we've had though
fuller not really a sponsorship
opportunity but the rocks tequila Tara
mana yeah it was like super strong and
like you wouldn't want to just drink it
straight up yeah maybe it's made for men
no I dream nomad like him but then maybe
when you drink it
Oh whether we had a castle migos which
is George Clooney's brand and me
personally I'd rather be towards clean
on the rock cuz the game would be George
Clooney instead of the Roth hell yeah
what why he was on Ocean's eleven yeah
but the rocks are [ __ ] object like
he's a rock no but I mean but the girls
want to [ __ ] him oh I would say more
girls wanna [ __ ] I joined Clooney on the
rock so you want more girls to fall on a
[ __ ] yes well that's assuming I would
always want more girls to other I I want
whoever has the more sensitive dick cuz
what if the rock emotionally sensitive
not like what if what if the rock was
like the rock is that a callous dick
yeah it is yeah give me that callous
yeah we do about this he enjoy what you
feel then why would you wanna be him
then yeah see it I want to be [ __ ] by
him if it's gonna feel good but I don't
want to be him so then we go back to him
wanting to get the ladies but it yeah
but what if George Clooney's dick is too
old too bright because the rock is
walking out maybe maybe means in the
prime in this product yeah both people
that our product is George Clooney now
that's different not 90s rock no he's in
his prime now is one is
that now I feel like George Clooney's
way more chill with work and everything
yeah like with a rock is constantly go i
hustles you probably have time to [ __ ]
you know that's true that's true that's
like you know sources all the [ __ ] huh
the outsources yeah guess he could only
a lot of times has times for like
history i'm stories where he's drink
when you guys drink together do you guys
play spin the bottle it's been the
bottle never played spinner ever yeah
say i'm like i don't think i've ever
know it's like I've seen it in movies
I've never played spin the bottle either
and I always wish people were gonna play
no wait I like oh you did placement
mm-hmm recently was it guising good way
to tell it was like eight months ago
with a mouse there it was all female
thank God like you and your roommates
eight months ago when I was at the party
it that you weren't invited to so every
time you guys have girls over you're
like I know you know whatever your girls
over it's literally it's like an
individual thing it's like one one
person has you know a girl over and they
just shutter themselves in the room I
thought it was like everyone else was
like alright girls are here in a deem
you know what to do and you go to
Annoying little brother bring a loud
Bell you just like shake a can of coins
in your room when mike has a good girl
that he doesn't really like if you have
us come back oh my god that's not a
thing like I don't to be a third wheel
is like please do you want to just bring
them over you didn't this this is a over
one instance yeah i thankfully not you
know you meet people online or whatever
dating app and you know you don't go
okay I'm done go home now you feel bad
you know you meet somebody there's
always a high jump
I can't relate bros like I don't know
man it's like I think it's differences
because like she was super cool were
like it's not where to bring it around
your friends and she just gets along
where it's like sometimes if you bring a
girl like you don't want her to meet
your friends yeah I just wasn't feeling
it you know it's like you meet somebody
else trying to save it be like she was
super cool with that rule it's a yeah so
it's kind of like all right you know I'm
not gonna prolong this and be like just
like I might as well just pretend like
I'm into this and then it just ends up
more complicated or hurtful for you know
the other person's you're just kind of
like I'm gonna chill and you know after
a reasonable amount of time be like all
right you know this is this has been fun
but like time to go home no but it was
like how do you do that could I swipe
you how'd he do that delicately you know
so my brother says his boss does this to
him every time he goes over to his
boss's house and he goes man look at the
time if this wasn't my house I'd be
going home yeah that's really forward
push I use I could use that I had work
to do
oh well now you just blew it you can't
do that anymore
ya know what now I feel like you could
just be like like gotta come we gotta
stay on your toes I didn't know my way
out and I found the way I found that was
like all right you know I got I got yeah
so it's not normal to after you come you
go I finish and then you walk out this
was this is kinda your own we leave me
hook up it was just kind of like I'm not
even minute like I'm not even interested
you do in that situation that's what I
mean like afterwards
[Laughter]
I've got clarity now and started
bringing here but you know yeah do you
jack off before of when you guys were
dating like before I go why would you
waste it that's like eating before you
go to dinner with Innosight don't you
last longer ah a little bit longer it
could be it depends on how long the nut
between the nut was yeah it was like if
you if you didn't nut sense like let's
say it was Sunday now it's Friday and
you didn't jack off since Sunday and you
do jag off Friday before you're gonna
last longer than you would if you
wouldn't have all right too much math
you lost me but I know you don't want to
jack off before you're your hookup
because you want your day up because you
want your load to be bigger why do you
want a bigger look why
I don't know that one press this field
effect until you graduated yeah yeah
when the load is bigger the orgasm is
bigger to like it you look like because
it's prologue or like yeah but you want
that clarity yeah you want you it's like
not just about like the the sex about
that clarity night you're like am I just
doing this because I'm super horny yeah
yeah but you got a time that because you
don't want to be too clear we were just
like this is only post clarity not
clarity there's like maybe 45-minute
hour later clarity that's a little bit
more clear y'all locked up for failure
that's good that's good for you at this
point also let's hit up girls how much
of a benefit and then we're like oh [ __ ]
I forget he's gone guys are really dumb
really are through your mind when you're
hooking up with a guy then like what
kind of benefits me well what then what
situation no like that to make me won't
have sex with me if that's that's our
thought process going into a hooker we
don't need Claire we're pretty clear
dude I think that girl's determined
mainly when they're gonna when we're
gonna get laid like they're already
prepped true if you notice like their
legs are shaving they're clean like they
thought of this before yeah coming over
well that's our our clarity clarity
clarity is after I think you guys have
clarity before yeah yeah yeah yeah cuz I
get up girls
we're like they're gonna come over that
night or later plan it and then I jerk
off and then I'm like oh no like I don't
want them over and then I was a gives up
he's gonna come over I got think clear
and then you coming you're like [ __ ] I
don't want you to come over no water
come over it's just a real one that's
love oh that's love love means
interesting that is it's very
complicated that's because that doesn't
work for me I'll still come and still
hook up that's love it's not because it
it's the same even if it's a hookup oh
yeah I'm horny man is it for you since
you've gotten older
40 yes and no but not for the same
reasons because it's right now feeling
like it never happened
because doors I I feel like when I was
sexless in a relationship that's when it
killed my libido the most a little
psychological and now that I'm single
it's right back up yeah it's like it
never happened
so that's what kind of freaked me out
yeah but when I was 23 I went through
the same experience and then it wasn't
relationship it was just high stress
I was working graveyard for like months
and I got extremely sick and that was
the lowest my libido was I had IDI I was
like what the [ __ ] I'm old and my dick
we'll never get home 23:23 I thought I'm
scared it was like is this what this
mean when you're aging and then it was
just obviously stress never seeing the
Sun never working now just being
completely like unhealthy and and just
all that [ __ ] right and then because I
know that I feel like edy and stuff in
at a later age is probably because more
lifestyle than anything else yeah I
think it'd be you know is like it's not
a hundred percent like a lot of its
psychological psychological that's all
like how healthy you are with your
relationships with your work life all
that stuff is desperate but I'm still
horny I think that's a difference when
you get older so the same things that
used to turn you on because you never
had it is it's I think it's you're more
sensitive cuz cuz when you're younger
you're like when you see if girlfriend
over it's like oh my god I got to go
jack off when you're older you still
think damn but I got things to do when I
was in high school and then I was
talking to a girl I like trying to I
already just by talking are like should
give me a hug I'll get like a phoner
yeah and then so you'd like hide in
something
what's a good boner hug because there's
any just talking to me I was so little
imp like hugs that are like don't get
your germs on me just talk those are
ones that are like
a guy in there but sticking away from
you they're just trying to vote her home
like if I could feel a girl's boob if a
great my shoulder cook and I was even
looking like I could feel that was a
booth when do you think that'll happen
for you huh what do you think for you
huh when do you think that'll happen for
you one day I'm like thinking the idea
of it just but then now it's like I
could like I could be dad it was all
over anyway
and then it's like and that's like I'm
China nothing will happen you know I
feel like it's like pre version and post
version so like I don't know if it's
quite an age thing but if I probably was
a virgin till now my level of excitement
with a woman would be like oh my god I
touched her right versus like now you're
just kind of like ah because that's all
speculation they say it's like yeah I
could [ __ ] late but what about the girls
really [ __ ] hot like it's completely
different than what I'm used to because
I think it's a novelty thing more than
it's like a I'm getting old and tired
because I still have the same motivation
but maybe I want something different
you're becoming more like attuned to
what you actually like sexually versus
just like sex in general I guess I just
want to have sex now you're like what
actually turns you on what are you like
now that you're older maybe more like
sexually confident you're just kind of
you've had some experiences like I don't
like that that doesn't turn me on or
like yeah at the end of day you're gonna
be like I can sex sex I'm horny I'm
gonna have it but other things would be
like I'm super into this for whatever
reason that you know I wanna get punched
your face or lie on the table that's
what you figured out yeah like whatever
did yeah and I want to keep doing that
yeah cuz back then I wasn't trying to
get a limb I was like jobs are amazing I
was like hand jobs hey let's do a job
don't even turn your anymore the rim job
done angels are cool but now yeah I'm
looking for that rim jobs so if a girl
sticks her hand down her pants and she
starts going to the back first you're
like hey
she's just pressed she's warming it up I
was wondering like Joe like when you
push there no one say that really keeps
going and that's why you shave your
[ __ ] okay nobody knows what you're
talking about that's another video yeah
I was about I think it's it's a it's a
it's a novelty thing well he's for me
what I'm like oh that doesn't [ __ ] do
it for me it's like remember when we
went to the strip club in Vegas right
and in the day after we went to Zumanity
and there were so many titties but I was
just like oh it's Nancy time I saw so
many titties yesterday with Zumanity
yeah absolutely but they're like topless
yeah what the hell it's a Cirque show
yeah there's like Tiger ladies with
boobies and [ __ ] that's one thing I
didn't understand as a kid I remember
watching like a TV show maybe like 9 or
2 1 or something and they're talking
about like like lingerie or the way that
girl was dressed up to the imagination
I think guys like a junior high high
school kid I'm like [ __ ] imagination
just get her name yeah have you been
taking off to your imagination as oh
yeah they're like I like lingerie and
actual clothes on a little bit more than
just completely more fat woman but now I
understand [ __ ] what do you was
talking him to have porn in high school
I'm trying to Bobby do been [ __ ] people
Little Bo Peep there's two things I
heard that I just went like this too
but it was actually the deems did you
have poor like porn video we were
looking at ankles mags
I think fifth-grade is like first the
first porn internet porn experience from
for me was either you type in boobs no
it was actually spice channel scrambled
porn
yeah but it was that at the run the same
time as the internet came up but the
first porn thing I've ever had was
scrambled softcore porn on on the TV
where if you go to channel 97 that's
what it was for my TV it would be
scrambled porn and you watch it there
for a QC a booth just waiting for a tip
to like get through the scramble and
you're waiting for that was my first
experience of porn the next was boobs
calm and then it was a cos ah or
LimeWire where you just and you're just
like sitting there be like in 32 hours
it's like some [ __ ] virus that
goddammit you start all over but ya know
yeah we had we had video you'll never
know the struggles of [ __ ] closing
her eyes and jacking off to scrambled
porn cuz you should hear the [ __ ]
moaning man because your eyes you miss
the titty that's why you missed it so I
know that's true you gotta wait that's
like going to like the video store and
then there's the adult section if
they're right or physically like go to
the edge where it's not the adult
section you just keep looking at this
movie what's this movie about but you're
really just trying to look later you're
like oh yeah I'm gonna use this you're
like that's why you say [ __ ] imagination
the saloon double doors as if a kid
can't just go down and look at all the
[ __ ] videos as if the kid just
doesn't want to go through saloon double
doors in general regardless of what's on
the other side like Oh double doors
let's go through those so many doors
it's like guaranteeing the black
curtains have black turns yeah like
black wish it was a mission to be a perv
back then though like when you have to
actually go to that section and do your
thing you have to boldly like I'm
renting this today yeah yeah you'd have
to like your own alibi why am i back
here you see you see what event that you
immediately get there genre of porn well
yeah Plus also remember like what we
look up now it's like that
escalation of porn is not a new thing
necessarily like somebody who's been but
renting porn videos I start out like you
know softcore porn there now like I'm
into some weird [ __ ] now and you can't
just like privately search it you can
rent it yeah girl people
you really got to own it too my friend
had a little corner store with the like
a sexy room in the back
yet he could you could buy like the porn
right and then people will ask boldly
like do you have the girls with a milk
oh yeah I know you talked about yeah and
he's like what you're like you know like
like when they have the milk and they're
pushing it into the face and all that
pregnant like he's asking for specific
fetishes and genres saying what you
would type into google or type in a porn
out to a human being
yeah milked it's porn excuse me what you
know go get it you heard me I feel like
that should be a thing now cuz so it
limits on how much you do it because you
have to like like yeah I mean a human
being really wanted Instagram to get
allowed to do it or watch it yeah
hilarious like you have to really like
this [ __ ] cuz you got to own it yeah cuz
right now I feel like porn [ __ ] people
up alright kids up big time it's too
accessible and it's too good man too
stimulating it's like crack dude they
got way better back then I mean even the
girls weren't that hot you mean now it's
like you have supermodels and like just
regular as girls like there was a
pornstar look back then you know you're
like that's a pornstar
but now it's like just someone you went
to school with yeah who has a link in
their biases on your hands someone who
you literally went to school with me
that's my classmate yeah what's up how
you doing good I know the whole thing
and yeah I know I follow yeah
[Music]
[Music]